welcome to this video playing a
five-minute game against Ashley Tosh
Zhang Zhang account but no John Fleck at
least but yeah you never know whether
people are really from let's see moon
thought I can I can't help it it's
always funny this line reality leads to
boring positions and people don't really
place his sixth that often which seems
to be the most reliable response yeah
you get that quite often but this seems
to be really quite okay for white okay
so probably Bishop e3 even supporting de
for a bit young and now that's
interesting do I have they have to play
a five I mean okay I do not have to play
five that's clear but is it is it good
trying to get this night from f6 I can
also just play a move like Bishop e2
securing the center it's also d5
actually it's also not that again
dropping back to e2 after a move like 95
after the capture I will check with the
pawn you take with the pawn and now he
needs to go to this somewhat strange
square on or to some other was queried
don't does not want to go to the if I
was my idea actually he five and then f4
after which I threatened to take on edge
five so I think he basically must take
and this looks like a pretty good
position in my book h5 is a simple
threat now I can castle oh of course
young take it or castles long I guess
that sets quicker that's the quicker way
to play and do then aged five there's
also the idea to play six and Quincy
form also quite good but ok he needs to
address the idea of h5 I think you know
it was stuff i don't i didn't really see
anything against that ok now i can take
here and play Queen g42 age for with the
temperature another's Quincy for as well
Quincy forecheck King edge atrium that's
not not yet winning but very close the
rogue age seven sacrifice
Queen g4s of course also very good yeah
how to say chattering this is the sister
also quite good now a queen e6 intending
to take on g6 and to take on d7 you can
try queen bee seven with the counter
threat on be too
come on I had all day they have this
drilling sounds in my in my room from
from some neighboring house so it's
killing me unbelievable okay let's still
check I can calculate that this is a win
right check Bishop age six Queen f7
black resigns yeah h4 is really
dangerous it's uh it's mean it's as
simple as that and I'm not sure how to
assess this maybe this is still a
playable line for black but it's it's
getting really dangerous quickly check I
don't I don't really know i mean this
this already looks looks tricky to me
you had the computer agrees and gives a
wide a very big advantage almost a win
actually he must do something else
before not quite sure what it is what he
should do I mean besides the fact that
after age 40 c 6 is a very solid choice
yeah i'll stop this video now this noise
is colin is driving me insane i'm sorry
for that thanks for watching anyway